all right I'm talking about component
izing end-to-end tests so this is my
first time being at a conference
speaking so let me start with thank you
so I'm gonna start with some icebreaker
questions that make me feel better so
who here is written web applications
looks like quite a bit
all right who's written a unit tests
yeah all right so who writes and n tests
using Cypress test cafe selenium
webdriver etc okay less people all right
so who thinks that they're easy to write
the bug or maintain not about very many
hands okay cool so this talk will help
all right so I'm gonna put a statement
out there that writing and then test is
hard so one thing is figuring out how to
select something do you use there's all
kinds of different things do you even
control what they are gonna be race
conditions both in your applications and
also maybe in your test runner data can
be hard to control and also UI changes
tend to break tests I know that for the
last five years at a company we had a
offshore doing R and n tests for us and
they were they had an entire team just
trying to keep those tests running
because obviously the U I was changing
constantly and so the tests were
constantly breaking so now that I've
postulated all that I'm nicholasville
I'm a design system engineer at workday
the design system and engineers kind of
what it sounds like I'm an engineer on
the design system it's work day the
design system is called canvas it's open
source in July so how do we break down
our applications because we have to
build complex applications so how do we
do it so this is just a screenshot that
I took from Sanchez website they have a
it's like a kitchen sink example of just
a complex application that's just like a
dashboard some menu items and stuff so
when we look at this we probably try and
visualize how we would break this all
down and we will probably draw boxes
around that like layout boxes we might
even call these components and obviously
this application has multiple widgets
those widgets have titles we can start
to see some common themes I added some
color coding so like a the menu has many
items and I've outlined that with purple
and widgets have kind of outlined with
red and then their titles I outlined
with yellow so we can kind of see these
patterns of repeating pieces that repeat
over and over and over again and this
big problem was broken down into small
pieces and then kind of built up to make
this complex dashboard application so
how would we get target that email icon
so maybe we wanted to click on it so
that one right there so we might choose
the first option I had which was a
selector this is an option this is
called XPath hopefully you don't use
that it's very fragile you can see the
numbers in brackets like three that's
the third div under the body and then
that was a second div under that one and
the first div under that one and then
the anchor tag you could maybe use the
class name that seems a little bit more
stable maybe that was a problem that we
had with our offshore team they used
they tried to figure out what selector
would be best
obviously XPath changed to more often so
they tried class names but if we go to
things like CSS and j/s those class
names are changing constantly so another
option might be like a data test ID that
is something that we could control and
it made it a little bit more obvious
that that was something specifically for
testing so that developers didn't
accidentally change that too often but
then the next question is what are these
selectors go where do you put them so
one option is co-located with your
source code that seems like a pretty
obvious choice I've got the import react
statement at the top I and then I'm just
gonna go ahead and export a conch called
selector and I'll just name it data test
ID email so now you can just grab
that selector now you can grab that icon
you can see that's matched to the icons
data test ID inside that email icon
component so some pros and cons so it's
very easy at the unit testing level
it's nice and collocated it's easy to
tell where it is it could be bad friend
and testing so I don't work for Cyprus
but I've contributed there so they gave
me a nice t-shirt so if you did this in
a Cyprus test the way they do that is
every test becomes its own small
application that it wraps up into like
it injects itself into your applications
page so what ends up happening is
instead of just grabbing all of your
your test code it also is now grabbing
the whole of react so that can that can
be bad it will slow down your tests
because it has to compile an arsenal
that the entire application not just
test code so the next thing that we
tried doing was doing a global selectors
file where we just list it out and tried
to add names to all the selectors now
this is a nice list because everything
has test IDs but we had complicated CSS
selectors before it was a little bit
more obvious what was nice as this was
in our source code so that we could at
least see what it was where before it
was in a different repository in a
different technology that we didn't have
secure access to so we couldn't even see
what selectors the offshore team chose
so this was at least a little bit better
we could import them all and then at the
bottom we just said this is all my
examples in our in Cyprus but this could
work for any testing framework so we
just got this we just called this I dot
get which you just give it a CSS
selector and then we could go on with
that so there's some pros and cons of
that it's easy to tell where everything
is at once but it's not modular if
you've done some Redux stuff and you
have all your actions in one place that
works out pretty well until you get to a
certain scale and then that file is just
huge and you accidentally add selectors
multiple times because there's just the
list is just too long so you could have
local selector files so that's what we
ended up moving to next
so we had each area had its own kind of
selector thing so all the icons had a
selector and then all of the like maybe
cards had a selector and and then just
an index file we just reordered
everything so now we could just do name
spacing so now I have a site get
selectors that icons dot email is a
little bit cleaner so there's more
modular but then we quickly ran into an
issue where our selector is powerful
enough we have complex applications so
we have more and more complex app
interactions to do something that we
want to do it's pretty easy to describe
in English but it was harder to do in
our implementation especially if it had
to be repeated so how do you target an
item on the this to do and then check it
off so I'm talking about this one down
here so that first one you might do
maybe maybe you'd say that could be that
XPath or maybe you would get all the
to-do items and then pick the first one
but maybe we want to just grab it by
something that we can see within the
application so we might want to grab it
by that name now some of you might be
alluding to the next part could we just
use oops sorry that took a little bit
this was too complicated for our
selector so we had to look for something
else so I said before all them examples
are in Cyprus but it could work for any
framework so some of you have heard of
react testing library so originally that
started as react testing library and
then it was kind of abstracted into
testing library that added adaptors for
a bunch of different things including
react view Cyprus puppeteer and test
cafe so I remember first hearing about
that on for Cyprus so they even have one
helper for react select and that
actually I was surprising to me because
we were doing that I think before
testing library added it but it's on
it's on one of the listed as one of
their adapters so I saw that thought
that was pretty cool because it was kind
of long that same idea so this is if you
are using the to do
using the testing library with the self
Cypress adapter you would use query by
text and just say upgrade to SSD hard
disks and then you would click on it and
then hopefully it doesn't actually work
with how Sencha implements their
application but let's pretend that it
does so that's cool if you have the
selectors that would work well for how
the react testing library does which is
around text and it also has nice helpers
around forms but what if your stuff is a
little bit more specific like the Sencha
application where it doesn't quite work
like a modern application would the Dom
would work so you need something a
little bit more custom to get the right
thing
so I coined it as component kind of
opponent helpers or basically component
helper functions or helper functions we
had a few different names for it so they
look kind of like this so the first
thing I did is just created a function
called get to do by name you pass in the
name and what it does is it returns you
a cypress chainable object by some
selector now the only place that that
selector is available is inside of the
helper itself so your test code doesn't
actually deal with it at all the next
one is just getting a checkbox so given
that to-do item we want to find the
checkbox within it and then the last one
is just getting we want to check that
to-do item and you can see I'm starting
to compose some of those helpers within
the same file together so it check to-do
item is now getting that item but its
name it's then getting the check box out
of it and then it's clicking on it so it
kind of looks like this we wanted to
first check that to-do item and then we
wanted to grab it and then get the check
box and then do an assertion on it and
make sure that it's checked now you
notice there's no selectors and it is
kind of like the whole thing around page
objects where you're not dealing with
the underlying driver directly you're
kind of working it a little bit higher
level of abstraction and then it comes a
little bit more it's not exactly English
it's not like cucumber but it's a little
bit it's it's fairly easy to read and
understand what's going to
happen this worked well for our PM's in
our QA to be able to have some
confidence that we were doing the
testing that we wanted to do and that we
said we were doing so other components
obviously like a button probably doesn't
need much for helpers because all you
can really do is is click on it and
maybe you sorted on its text but there
could be other things so components with
portal content now portal is kind of
something that was coined by react I
think an angular before they call it
transclusion but it's basically taking
content and projecting it to another
place within your component tree so like
a modal if you can imagine a modal's
like a picture frame and you want to
take the picture and shove it into this
frame and the modal component is the
frame and your content is whatever you
want to put in that frame so that's what
I describe this portal content something
that moves somewhere else
portal specifically is actually going to
be something different in the Dom so
it's not gonna be as it's not gonna be a
direct child it's gonna be related maybe
through an aria Owens tag but it's gonna
be basically put at the bottom of the
dom so that it's not confined by the
same it's not confined by the overflow
of the container of the target so
modal's will do that so that it's not
it's not clipped by whatever that
Karthik target is contained in so that
can be tricky because it's not you can't
just find it it can't just take the
target and then just do a dot find
because now it's gonna be scoped to the
document instead of to the that
component so hierarchal menus if we have
multiple layers of a menu you have to
click on it to open it then you have to
find your item and then you have to
click on it and then it opens up another
submenu and then you want to click on it
that can be more complex where you just
want to describe the hierarchy of it to
select what you want another one might
be combo boxes we might have some
complicated things around how you'd
select things especially if there's some
virtualization going on cards you might
want to just say I want a card of some
domain type like I worked into the cyber
security company so we had things like
alarm cards and case cards so we wanted
to just select that card by its name but
we wanted to get the card and not the
text so we could just have a
opponent that would grab the card by
whatever the name contained or a D and
then returned that card and do other
actions on it like changed the status
dashboard widgets
similar to the example that I had and
the biggest one at the company I worked
with was virtual lists we had virtual
lists for everything which definitely
made testing things harder because we
couldn't just grab something in the DOM
and then click on it because it didn't
exist in the Dom it was virtual so now
I've got a demo of how I've done that
using react select virtual eyes I don't
know if anyone's used that before so
this is kind of what it looks like this
is with eight thousand items in it so as
I'm scrolling it will actually keep
going it's not its opening and closing
pretty instantly because there's it's
only rendering exactly what you see it's
using react virtualized under the hood
and it will just go on and you can
scroll quickly and get to everything so
I've got a simple spec here that just
grabs it so this is without any
component helpers this is just we are
going to grab it we have to know what
the selector is gonna be we have to know
what the next thing is going to be which
in this case I want to open it I want to
find something that contains the number
five and I want to click on it and now
I'm going to make an assertion that it
still contains that 5 so I have
selectors in here I have to know the
implementation details of how this thing
works so I've got this first test and
this is what it looks like it should it
should just work it looks fine so why
would I need any help her for this well
if the item I happen to want to be be
selecting is not on the first viewable
page right now that's an implementation
detail for how the component works so
let's say I wanted to select the item
number 100
so we'll just change this right here to
now this should reload and it's gonna
sit here and wait and it will eventually
fail because it can't actually click on
an option that has the string 100 on it
because it's it's down there now
interestingly enough if i refresh this
and manually scroll it down to the item
of 100 it will pass
so to most people implementing it that
just happens to be an implementation
detail it's not something that I
necessarily care about all I really want
to do is select this very specific
option within this list the fact that
it's virtualized I shouldn't really have
to care about it could be it could be
not virtualized at one point virtualized
later and I shouldn't really have to
care about that difference but it went
through and it did everything that you
would expect it grabbed the this item by
this selection it went ahead and clicked
on it then it found an item that
contains 100 it clicked on it and then
it ran an expectation against that to
make sure that it contained this - 100
on there so I just looked at the
implementation of react select virtual
eyes I've never actually used it before
so I just made those those helpers so I
just made some way of getting the
component so that you can just call it
you just import this this function and
then you just call it then the Select
was a little interesting so what I ended
up doing was I I first grabbed that
element and I click on it just to open
it then I end up getting this selector
here which normally you never have to
think about but this is the this is the
overflow container that contains all the
virtualization so what I'm doing is I'm
scrolling that so I'm sending a scroll
event
I'm telling that container to scroll a
little bit and then I do an assertion on
it to see if the item that I wanted is
there and if it's not then I'll keep
scrolling and I'm tying it to
requestanimationframe to make sure that
react fully flushes to the Dom before
that's done so here's the implementation
of scroll to so this component opens it
or this helper opens it it grabs that
container it tells it to scroll to and
it gives it a nice long
time out so that doesn't the default is
four seconds and it might take us longer
so I just set that about to about ten
seconds and then once I found it then
I'm gonna go ahead and click on it so
what the scroll to does is it's just a
it's an async function it takes in a
match and returns an async function that
is then returned then it takes in that
element and it will continuously look
for any to see if there's a Dom any node
in this node list that contains that
string that you gave it and if it
doesn't if the length is zero it will go
ahead await a requestanimationframe
cycle to make sure that the Dom has been
properly flushed it will set the scroll
table to be plus 20 this is just for
demo purposes I actually made it in
production go a lot faster so that it's
gonna scroll about one page at a time
but it's hard to see what's going on so
after that then it just calls the scroll
top sets it to the new scroll top
position and then when it's done it will
return that element so that it can be
clicked on it later so what that ends up
looking like so the same thing I'm going
to select that same item number 100 and
now I'm using my nicer API so I'm just
calling a get select which is returning
Cypress chainable objects I'm using
pipes so if people have used Cypress
before pipe is actually a plugin that
I've made it's similar to dot then it
just does a little bit nicer outputting
which I'll show in a bit and then I just
type in that select function that I
imported and then I just give it what
string I want it to match and then later
I get that same select and I'm just
doing an assertion of that containing
this text string so now this is what it
ends up looking like it's going to
scroll through automatically on its own
and find the thing it's a right item so
now I don't actually care if it's
virtualized or not if it happens to be
viewable or not it'll just run through
now when I talked about pipe this is
what pipe gives me it gives me a nice
little item here tells me what function
was called as well as a before and after
that call so if you use a dot then it
doesn't actually show you any nice
things in the in the log here so I'll
slow that down a little bit and we'll
watch that it's kind of it's kind of fun
to watch one that's running so we'll
just slow it down to maybe like eight
pixels at a time so you can see it's
scrolling a lot slower but it's the same
basic concept and then once it finds the
item it'll either time out because I
can't find it
or it will scroll enough that it finds
it it'll select it and then they will
move on alright so component helpers
help us abstract our implementation
details just like components our
contract for developing our UI component
helpers are a contract for testing our
UI so we've we ended up proving this
over the course of two years but the
implementation can be changed without
our test braking as long as those API
contracts were the same for our
component helpers as long as our
implementation our component helpers
were updated with the implementation
nothing that ended up breaking how we
ended up doing it is our component
library was pushed into our local NPM
repository our helpers were also pushed
to that same repository under like a
slash helpers
so our C I was tied to testing out our
helpers of our components so we could
guarantee that as long as our api's did
not change the application test would
not break if they did we our CI would
catch it before it ever got to that at
that point so what ended up happening
was all of our application failures were
because the application was breaking
some specification of the application
changed not because the components
changed
so component helpers can be composed so
we ended up proving this out far we had
a multiple component libraries and the
leaf the leaf node the lowest level one
of our design system it had these
component helpers for the very very
basic low level components and then
those were consumed by higher level
component libraries and those were
concerned consumed by widget
repositories and then eventually it was
consumed by the application so each
level created their own helper
abstraction layer and it kind of built
on top of it so when we had more come
with in our dashboard example we had
some of those widgets or those apps they
had some complex interactions and we
just had easier ways of dealing with
them like one of them was like an
identity list and it was using this idea
where it would scroll through identities
and searching for if it expected there
to be an identity anomalous identity
risk above some certain level it made it
a lot easier to just give it at some
risk that we wanted it to test against
and then grab it and then move on so
here's some of the links that I had
first ones designed at work day comm
that's work days of design system
there's the react Dom testing library
here I have a link to the Sencha
dashboard example that I had and then
Cypress that I
there's no timer up here so I have no
idea where I'm at
all right and this talk is supposed to
end and I'm actually done I hope I don't
didn't leave too much time left
[Applause]
[Music]